you marry this guy he you're super
attracted to him he is the perfect guy
it is just from time to time he steps
out but you will never know when it's
happening
and this sounds like some tristan
tristan going no no tristan no it's not
tristan thompson because tristan
thompson was hooking up with girls in
public okay yeah
and the world nobody would know about it
no one would know you know that he can
do it and that if he does do it
and if you do find out it's just gonna
be an escort because that's what you pay
for you pay for
um you pay you pay basically that
they're clean and that no one finds out
that is their job
do you think women i think it's just
morals but i don't know
do you think women then care more about
the embarrassment that comes from yeah
yes absolutely a hundred thousand people
so you you care more about how other
people perceive your relationship than
the actual relationship itself sure i
mean the same way the same way if a girl
is disrespectful behind the scenes to
her man it's a different thing than if
she's disrespectful
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay okay
men and women think differently
yeah right i mean i think but i'm saying
it's about the disrespect like publicly
yeah
wait are you sorry are you saying
women care more about what people think
of their relationship
no i'm not saying that i'm asking
whether
you would care more about how other
people perceive the fact that your man
has cheated on you or whether the fact
that your man has cheated on you what
what what would be your priority but in
your head the fact that your man's
cheating on you is always there speaking
to the microsoft sorry the fact that
your man's cheating on you is always in
your head so like that's just going to
be eating it away at you whether he's
doing or not the fact that he can do it
is just eating away at you the whole
relationship and then that's just going
to play yeah if you don't mind me asking
have you ever been cheated on
no okay so it's very hard to scare me
it's very hard to have that kind of kind
of conversation because you don't know
what it's like
what tends to happen is a girl will
leave
if she thinks she can do better
or get a man that of better value than
the man she's with however if she
doesn't think she can get any better
than him
she will figure out a way to make
probably make him feel bad but she will
stay
so then what comes into play is okay
stay at what cost
all right then if i
can figure out a way that oh my man's
gonna cheat on me
but no one's ever gonna find out
i can live with that and i get money
cool because he's gonna do it anyway
some girls look at the mistress some
some girls look at the side piece as an
employee like that is how they think of
them like you were you were just the
host they were doing it that would be a
good way because
because you go mad okay perfect
if
like you said about the feelings thing
like if you
keep it on your personal thing you're
gonna go mad someone's dying
your mind is doing his thing with
someone else yeah it's gonna be hard for
you to think of this woman on the same
level as yeah
yeah so
employee you're going to see as an
employee then come because it's just
like okay
this is basically they're working for me
i mean
sort of yeah
some girl i mean i'm talking about
escorts but there's some side chicks
that do it for free
they just want that they just want to
thank you yeah but like as the wife you
get your name on the on the deed you're
on the life insurance you're you have
his children yeah where she's just
things don't matter anymore because if
this is an open marriage now because
what no no it's open it's not going to
be open it's going to be open though
because no one knows because it's a
contract
what kind of silly contract is days
sorry
don't get me wrong though it only
applies to men of high value or yeah
like the average man cannot do that no i
know
who you think you are of course not
do you see how you don't respect the
average man as well okay don't stand up
crazy because you're crazy
it's fair it's what you believe and it's
how you perceive him and that's
completely up to you but it could be
vice versa it's true
if that's me like mama if my mom would
look at me like that he would be like
what are you doing
right but men and women are different
but in different things
so women are valued by men and men
seek the validation of other men
go back to men because because because
men run the world good for people sadly
not just true true
fathers
i mean
men don't disagree guys
men built the world
like they built the world we live in
and um it's it's unfortunate i mean i
don't even want to say it unfortunately
i'm very grateful they did that because
we couldn't do a lot of the things we do
today without it but
i mean it's just men's
as your value as a woman is based on at
least in the sexual marketplaces based
on what men want you unless you're gay
but that's like a different thing
have you ever heard the phrase um
every building you ever see was built by
a man every person you ever meet was
birthed by a woman yeah yes yes i like
that phrase a lot because it's just
nobody would be here without a woman
exactly and no building would be without
a man yeah
someone said they disagree i didn't see
who it was it was me so you don't think
then what would you disagree with i
don't remember
that men
men wonder what what just because they
because of what they build and what like
why why why do you say that men won the
world well because men occupy most of
the power positions and they run most of
the fortune 500 companies
they they're in all we don't have that
is true
i mean i will say i think
we're never given the truth exactly
we're never given the choice in order to
get to those positions because men are
always there to
oh no that is that is
oh my gosh no you could you guys are all
capable of being a fortune 500 ceo i
just doubt many of you i agree with that
i just don't want to yeah you just don't
want to most women don't want to they
want to have kids and start a family
like
high hype and lawyers right so there's a
law firm in canada and they they wanted
to get there
they could not keep their high-end
lawyers after the age of 35 because they
could not pay those women enough to stay
because in order to get to those
positions positions you have to work 80
90 hour hour weeks
sounds terri i don't want to do that
but there's nothing do you think there's
something stopping us
well in the sense of like
i guess it all goes back to our role is
to have kids and have and raise the
family but like
why do we have to raise the fact that
obviously we have the kids and so we
have to raise family but like why is you
you talk about what is it compromise
cooperativeness cooperation so
where is the the splitting of the roles
where the man takes time off as well to
raise those kids and the women can carry
on with her career and everything so
they're both rising at similar levels so
we have the choice to do that it's just
i think
we don't want to
most women i mean i don't know about you
but if i had kids i would hope to stay
home with them for the first five years
and i think as women we just have more
of a natural inclination to to want to
be with our children yeah i mean when
you i just think
mothers have a specific bond to their
child that it's not the same for men
yeah it's just nature
like if i if i'm really sad and
emotional like i always want to go to my
mom
don't give me and and i respect how like
everyone on my channel will tell you
that i talk so highly of my dad but if
i'm going to cry like i want to go to my
mom
and that's just i don't know i think
women have a different bond with their
children yeah
[Music]
you know me personally if um if i were
ever blessed to have a child
don't get me wrong i would love to stay
at home
i would love to just if i had the money
to just stay at home and chill with my
kid
chill with my young one and watch him
grow watch him walk watch whatever
i would love to do that
but the reality is i know that as a man
it is my job to provide for my family if
i'm not providing for my family what's
the point sticking around with this kid
watching him grow up if i can't give him
what he needs do you know what i mean
and regardless of what people say
like there you can literally watch it
might be anecdotal but you can literally
watch like videos where there's a baby
in the middle dad on one side mom on one
side they're both like comic come here
kid come in oh yeah always go to the mum
not always
not always all right okay okay all right
maybe not always but
the point that i'm trying to make though
is that
fathers are extremely important
and they need to be around in their
child's life like working 80 hours a
week like your father god bless him
but i'm sure you you might felt feel
like you missed out certain aspects
[ __ ] i don't got college dad i'm
chilling
i can hang out with this place
my dad's retired i can hang out with him
all right yeah yeah yeah that's that's
wonderful you know i mean um
but like what like that that time though
where you're watching the child grow
that's like such a
it's a magical time they're changing
every month
and
honestly as perhaps it's my temperament
perhaps i have a more feminine
temperament i feel a degree of jealousy
towards women that have the capacity to
just stay at home and be with that child
because don't get it twisted fathers
love their kids just as much as moms do
you know i mean
um ideally anyway
but
you know we have a duty that our purpose
is to provide for this family and that
means that we can't be at home all the
time
like that's the
that's the reality that's something that
i will have to face as someone that
would love to be a stay-at-home dad if i
had the money to do that
ish what are you thinking
i see your face
we went on the way up thank you
you got to donate so we can get issue
what is it
rations are quite funny sometimes
what is in your brain of yarmouth speak
up i disagree okay yeah go ahead but
this is just a personal thing and you
said yours was a personal thing
i think men
um
if
given the opportunity most men sorry
yeah yeah um
to stay in the house and watch their
kids grow
after a few days
yeah they'd be itching to go they'd be
agreeing
i think if you forgot your purpose as a
man if you forgot your purpose if you're
giving up your purpose as a man you're
giving up your path like your whatever
it is that you do that gives you
fulfillment the thing that allows you to
provide for your family if you're gonna
forego that just to stay at home then
yeah i agree you will get an itch
because you've you've given up your
purpose what about what about if you
have no purpose
you're a man you should have one
so you're i've just i've just found that
like masculine men that are like driven
and ambitious
they cannot sit still they cannot stay
home my dad if he was a stay-at-home
father
he would kill us
he would hate it one because he'd be
yelling at us like why aren't you
working
and and two like you you could not pay
that man to stay home and do nothing
he's retired now he hated he did it for
like six months and then he just started
another company because like those type
of men cannot sit still they have to be
doing something
and women it's just not the same like we
stay-at-home moms are one like have some
of the highest rated happiness right
like we we get fulfillment out of our
children i don't know men and women are
different i would imagine that it's not
the same for stay-at-home dads that like
they aren't as i don't know i don't i
haven't seen numbers
my intuition is telling me it's it's
probably not yeah yeah i think men
generally find a greater fulfillment in
their purpose that which the per their
purpose being whatever it is that they
do that gives them fulfillment and
allows them to provide for their family
right whereas for
uh women
i think it's generally their
interpersonal relationships their family
their community their immediate
community yeah
they find fulfillment in engaging with
that in a meaningful way